pop
[Musique]
à tous
aho
beau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui s'est passé vous n'avez
pas vu ma bicyclette non ma parole vous
l'avez fait exprès venons vous rouliez
trop vite je dormais mon vieux
[Applaudissements]
tant pis si kate n'avait pas été là pour
me réveiller les droits dans leur âme à
homs a retrouvé 80 mètres plus bas
mort certainement vous conduisez une
voiture comme celle là en dormant je
suis très fatigué ça fait trois nuits
que je ne dors pas le sommeil
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous avez l'intention de
payer la réparation de machines elle est
en usage ne m'embêtait pas avec votre
vieille bicyclette
j'ai joué ma vie j'ai gagné tant mieux
pour vous je crois au hasard à la chance
si vous préférez il fallait que je
tamponne
c'était obligatoire conduit chez moi la
gendarmerie pour quoi faire
je peux vous en prie en bicyclette 9
c'est pas vous plaignez vous alors vous
montez s'en va comme ça moi je m'en vais
maintenant si vous voulez rentrer à pied
ça vous regarde je vous accompagne et ça
à mon vieux clé avec moi
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
les années
j'ai soif
[Applaudissements]
la malade
vous voulez voir quelque chose rien ah
oui ce qui pour moi a chance
qu'est ce que c'est le signe
imprévisible de la destinée j'avais
rendez vous avec la mort au bad sera
vain mais la providence vous avez croisé
ma route
il ne faut rien exagérer qu'est ce que
vous faites dans la vie du touriste je
me promène aussi
et puis je joue dans les casinos
jacques lui ouest 1 et vous gagnez
quelquefois bon c'est pas mal par ici
vous êtes de la région
moi pas du tout je viens de paris avec
un top 9 comme celui qui par petites
étapes moyen de transport économique
en somme vous êtes en voyage je fais la
route paris allègre année à haute voix
oui vous connaissez la haute loire comme
ça qu'est ce que vous allez faire à
lèvres je viens de terminer mon endroit
je commence un stage de second clair
chez un notaire on m'attend à l'étude de
maître au couturier
ça change tout non mon vieux je peux pas
me laisser comme ça sur le bord de la
route
je vais vous conduire à aleg je veux
bien ça depuis c'est pas si loin où puis
je téléphonais merci
je me suis pas présenté reste liasse
mamoulian prayssac hommage à charles
auguste beauvallet charme et elle est
donc maintenant dans la batée ont vu un
coup de téléphone à dan et j'arrive
mettez la valise un coffre je suis navré
d'avoir défoncé
[Musique]
à l'aube a tué celle dont j'ai trouvé
quelqu'un non comme ça par hasard je
l'écrasé sa bicyclette tout à fait ce
qu'il nous faut jeune et naïf
il m'attend bien sagement dans la
voiture de la maine
[Applaudissements]
les bagues me gène peut conduire
contretemps mon vieux il faut absolument
que je sois à royat ce soir mais rien
n'est changé gérez vous conduira à
l'aigre demain nous allons passer la
nuit au grand hôtel je vous invite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais quelqu'un pour porter
novelli
[Musique]
est ce qu'on peut pour des valises dans
la voiture lequel valises monsieur les
bagages du prince mamoulian dans la
voiture blanche
vous avez réservé un appartement par
téléphone n'est ce pas monsieur oui on
va vous accompagner
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que je peux téléphoner en face de
vous mettre nos amis
allo alors je voudrais le 12 à la chaise
dieu c'est un café le bar fleuri à
l'oubli mon avis monsieur déodat
alors déjà dans l'appareil j'écoute par
fait très bien
je compte sur toi du gdam gens alors
vas-y ma petite fille est d'ailleurs tu
prévu au même endroit terminé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en
[Musique]
et
j'ai effacé vos affaires dans cette
valise ceci vous appartient merci
beaucoup à mon arrivée à allègre je vous
renverrai votre valise
puisque vous avez déjà joué de l'argent
oui le baccara nous commencerons par la
boule si vous permettez je ne sais pas
jouer je déteste ça en la circonstance
vokouma porte peu je voudrais que vous
preniez ma place ce soir au casino
vous oubliez que je dois commencer mon
stage lundi matin il serait mal élevé
d'être en retard en somme vous allez
faire le scribouillard juin auteurs oui
et après bush et un lit une nuit de
casinos représente pour moi beaucoup
d'argent vous comprendrez que j'y
attache plus d'importance qu'à vos
travaux d'écriture je vous donne
d'ailleurs l'assurance que vous serez
demain soir à l'air qu'il ne s'agit pas
d'un parent d'un caprice
vous êtes ma chance je ne vous lâche pas
je suis pas de smoking
même au liant à l'appareil
je voudrais louer un smoking pour ce
soir on va trouver moi d'ailleurs un
marchand dhabi je ne sais quoi
messieurs marc et déjà fait manger
[Applaudissements]
jouer un plein échange simple
s'il vous plaît maximum assez égalité
[Musique]
numéro un noir un père heyman maximum au
numéro rappel voilà numéro
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît monsieur merci personnel
qu'est ce que je dois faire laissez la
mise
[Musique]
e
monsieur marqué les jeux est plongé
[Musique]
allez je sois marquer
rien ne va plus
[Musique]
quatre rouges père heyman seulement en
continu jouer
[Musique]
là
en
[Musique]
à
néron mademoiselle
je voudrais regardez c'est interdit
on peut téléphoner au bar
[Musique]
rouge perret passe rien ne va plus
trois noirs un père heyman
cette fois c'est dans la salle de jeux
il est en train de perdre aucune
importance il est solide
inutile de me déranger pour me dire ça
[Musique]
je vous sers quelque chose
rien du tout hier à fait
continuer sans moi je vais chercher de
l'argent à la banque
à cette heure-ci savez moi j'ai pas
d'argent je ne vous demande rien numéro
16 numéros vous dépasser le maximum
[Musique]
e
à
2 11m à lyon
[Musique]
m
j'ai tout perdu aucune abstention
est-ce que je joue mal sûrement
on continue quand même une heure ou deux
c'est nécessaire entrez vous n'êtes pas
prêt
me dis qu'on partait ce matin impossible
je me repose je dois être à aller
aujourd'hui même
vous aviez promis de me conduire je joue
sans moi en tout cas sans vous
naturellement je suis navré d'avoir
perdu
je ne sais pas jouer je vous avais
prévenu vous avez joué avec mon argent
mon l'argent ne compte pas vous voulez
vous me donnez votre adresse je dois
vous renvoyez votre valise conserver là
je vous en fais cadeau si elle n'était
pas encore connue je l'accepterai
charles auguste mon ami vous êtes
ridicule avec cette comptabilité sordide
cette valise vous appartient je vais
vous la donner je ne vais pas accepter
si vous tenez tellement un voyage et
prenez ma voiture elle marche très bien
voici les clés je peux me servir de
votre voiture
oui la conduire moi même mais oui bon je
prenais la voiture je vous la ramènerait
samedi prochain je vous le promets cesse
puis chez mon appel et bon voyage
j'ai mon permis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
monsieur je vous en prie je vous en
supplie je vais rater mon train ou de
ces mois là car ils partent en trois
minutes même blagueur réguler ce n'est
pas parti tout de suite c'est trop tard
monter
ramesh marque très forte une catastrophe
ma mère m'a tant
courez vous allez la voir
merci monsieur
[Applaudissements]
parent
qu'est ce que vous faites là j'ai monté
mon train quel train il n'y a pas de
train il n'y a jamais eu de train
témoigne a pas de trains dans les gares
quelquefois mais à cette heure ci pas de
train savez vous voulez vous que je
demande un employé d'affiché moi la paix
ne vous occupez pas de moi et vous ça
c'est ennuyeux de vous laisser comme ça
dans une salle d'attenté je ne peux rien
faire pour vous vous n'allez pas me
conduire à saint georges d'aurac non
alors parce que vous allez à saint
georges d'aurac je vais à l'aigre mais
je dois changer à sa charge d'oracle 6
et allègre que vous allez je peut vous
conduire
tav attraper le maquis je n'ai aucun
mérite
je vais à l'aigre c'est un joueur
extraordinaire
merci a dit monsieur vous trouvez pas
que c'est merveilleux
comment vous appelez-vous barbara ça
vous plaît en général ça plaît aux
jeunes gens
[Musique]
les pas soif
on dresse arrêté dans un café pour boire
de la limonade
je n'aime pas beaucoup la limonade le
matin surtout buvait pas d'alcool jamais
boire d'alcool quand on joue
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
vous avez de la limonade à la nana le
coin de la limonade à la nana j'en ai
pas me séparer
[Applaudissements]
pour moi ce sera une eau minérale
pourquoi me regarde et vous comme ça je
trouve que vous êtes une drôle de
demoiselles je suis une demoiselle comme
malheureuse
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que je peux téléphoner non et
pourquoi pas ce qu'il y'a pas le
téléphone
y'a pas le téléphone pourquoi faire le
téléphone on s'en va vous n'avez plus
soif comme emmené dans un endroit
sérieux à l'endroit où il ya le
téléphone faut absolument que je
téléphone
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est fermé
je suis peut-être un discret mais à qui
voulez vous téléphonez à ma mère à
prévenir que j'arrive
mais ce matin à royat vous étiez
désespéré d'avoir manqué votre train il
vous était très facile d'expliquer ça
par téléphone à madame vous promets bien
sûr mais c'est pas à cause de ma mère
que j'étais désespéré il y a autre chose
oui il est autre chose
key a financé et vous allez bientôt vous
marier ça vous contrarie vous aimez
beaucoup votre fiancée oui non c'est
très difficile à expliquer j'ai un petit
coeur compliqué ça ne m'étonne pas
pourquoi vous êtes gracieuse gracieuse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
barbara revenait c'est ridicule c'est
pas téléphone c'est l'électricité et
hoda au téléphone
alors dans l'appareil j'écoute barbara
l'appareil je parle ça marche
j'ai vécu dans la voiture on arrive sauf
complication sera la tombée de la nuit
allo freddy ses traits dit comment ça va
mon poussin ça va pas mal c'est dur toi
c'est pour toi j'ai rater mon train
si si si si j'ai rater mon train et je
fais le voyage en automobile
howie très agréable très agréable
alors on va voir soyez pas jaloux
c'est ridicule freddy faisait d'un shu
mon amour je vis je ne veux pas vous
soyez méchant je t'embrasse
on l'adoré au revoir
je trouve que vous téléphonez beaucoup
de trop ça vous inquiète
ça m'ennuie mon petit charles auguste je
suis une femme qui doit organiser
j'ai entendu madame votre mère n'a pas à
se plaindre
c'était pas la mer c'était mon fiancé
je ne sais pas menti monsieur fredy et
s'appelle alfred
qu'est ce qu'il fait dans la vie votre
fiancée chez moi la paix avec ça après
tout ça vous regarde pas mes amours j'en
parlais pour vous être agréable
[Musique]
didon savent où je suis dingue
n'y touchez pas ce sont des bijoux de
famille balou soin de votre famille
pourquoi vous les mettez pas
ça me gêne pour conduire
[Musique]
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
charles auguste vous ne voudriez pas me
faire un plaisir un vrai plaisir
lequel passait par bellevue la montagne
c'est là que j'allais en vacances quand
j'étais petite fille bellevue la
montagne
oui oui j'étais la demoiselle de
bellevue-la-montagne proprement dite
route à droite et sebo par là du point
de vue surtout c'est peut-être beau mais
ça rallonge audit
on a tout son temps
je dois être à allègre ce soir à sept
heures et vous y serez c'est très bien
la sib it allègre amusez-vous mon garçon
mais aussi parce que l'avenir nous
réserve
[Musique]
e
je
[Musique]
à les regarder la rivière de mon enfance
barbara où allez vous baigner
reflet barbara revenez il est temps de
rentrer
retournez-vous charles-auguste je
retiens mes bas
barbara tout cela n'est pas sérieux
j'ai blocus et les filles tu trouves un
poisson rouge
[Musique]
allègre vous habiter chez madame votre
mère bien sûr vous pourrez allez vous
voir une fois de temps en temps où
habite madame votre mère rue du
capitaine commandant numéro 33 seulement
dans les petites villes pour conserver
sa réputation faut se tenir à carreau
pas de folie puis d'ailleurs je suis
fiancée alfred je n'avais pas oublié
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
barbara je suis amoureux de vous
je sais bien qu est ce que vous en
pensez
je crois que c'est dommage
pourquoi
la fête est finie nous pour partir et
les amis vont commencer
[Applaudissements]
non
non charles auguste qu'il faut pas m'en
passer pourquoi
ça serait pas bien à part
je ne comprends pas
vous n'allez pas tarder à comprendre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
discret
[Applaudissements]
barbara vous êtes tout de même une drôle
de fille voulait pas que je vous
embrasse il fut fait pour vous consoler
croyez que j'ai besoin de consolation
j'en ai bien peur qu est ce qui se passe
on est en panne
c'est peut-être les sens
pourquoi les sens vous vous y connaissez
un moteur non c'est bien ce que je
pensais tout ça c'est votre faute si on
ne s'était pas arrêtée on vous allez me
reprocher mon ban pied
les souvenirs sont l'auguste ça compte
aussi les souvenirs
il faut téléphoner un garage il doit y
avoir une maison par là là un château
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous allons vivre une nuit de rêve
je ne serai pas allègre ce soir quelle
importance
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la jolie petite jeanne d'arc
tu sais pas ça s'est cassé
à
madame nous sommes en panne de moteur
nous aurions voulu prévenir un garagiste
est ce que je peux téléphoner
qu'est ce que c'est des jeunes gens qui
demandent discours qu'ils entrent vous
avez entendu pensée pièce c'est madame
de la dernière vivant
le nom de la famille est inscrit par
deux sous l'eau
[Musique]
quand vient la nuit on se protège c'est
très vieux n'est-ce pas pour la peine de
le faire remarquer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
madame je vous présente mes excuses
notre voiture est en panne et je
souhaiterais prévenir à garagiste le
téléphone ne fonctionne plus et personne
n'a su réparer vous êtes à 14 kilomètres
du village le plus proche
je peux si vous voulez vous prêtez une
bicyclette mais dans nos régions les
garagistes ne surtout pas la nuit
enfin si vous voulez dormir ici c'est
facile ne sont pas les chambres qui
manquent
sans aucun confort d'ailleurs vous êtes
très aimable mais je crois que ces deux
jeunes gens qui vous demande
l'hospitalité chez les accueillir le spi
qualité pour la nuit qu'est ce que je
dois faire ça vous regarde
nous n'avons pas grand chose à vous
offrir toutes les chambres sont en
mauvais état mais si vous voulez vous ce
niveau jusqu'à la bibliothèque vous
pourrez toujours vous reposer mais vous
asseoir
en attendant monsieur je suis
extrêmement touché par votre accueil
mairie
[Musique]
j'insiste
ce n'est pas la première fois que ça
nous sommes ici à l'écart de tout droit
du monde des voyageurs égarés il y en a
toujours
à toutes les époques depuis la
révolution où ça a commencé
qu'est-ce qui a commencé des hommes
vous hâter de jeunes époux mademoiselle
et ma cousine du jeu l'a reconduit chez
sa mère peut vous appeler beauval et
pourquoi vous rêvez parce que c'est mon
nom vous n'êtes pas par an avec les pros
wallemme maubeuge non je ne les connais
pas ils sont tous morts d'ailleurs ce
doit être la raison ne croyez pas ça la
mort n'empêche rien après la mort tout
continue la gardienne il faut préparer
deux chambres pour ces jeunes jour celle
de laitages et carreau sans casser
d'oeufs puis quand j'ai vu ça l'autre
matin
c'est une maison où l'on craint ce book
les en ce moment c'est ainsi qu'anne
vous passerez une bonne nuit
soyez sans inquiétude vous avez dit
beauvallet charles-auguste beauvallet
excusé on ne reste pas on va s'en aller
moi je reste tout seul vous êtes
vraiment mal élevés nous n'allons tout
de même pas passer la nuit ici c'est pas
il n'y a pas de raison ça n'est vraiment
pas la peine de venir de si loin pour
être si bête babala vous en prie ses
filles comme ça
[Musique]
ouais
dit madame si vous pourriez nous
installer tout près l'un de l'autre
parce que seul dans une chambre
j'aurais peur
ici à coucher lamerat baisse qui ça
marguerite de saintes à lire une
religieuse qui a été persécuté pendant
la révolution française
ça fait rien je vais prendre cette
chambre aussi parce qu'elle est rose
dans les livres les jeunes filles
habitent toujours des chambres core os
on peut voir l'autre chambre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'orage non c'est madame caskill
caro elle fait s'envoler les objets il
se promène tout seul dans le château
pour des plafonds de temps en temps il y
en a un qui vient buter dans la fenêtre
il veut passer au travers
ça brise les carreaux
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
votre chambre n'est pas trop
inconfortable évidemment nous sommes à
la campagne
j'ai peur charge opus de quoi des
fantômes
regardez là derrière le rideau
pour
c'est une alcôve
qu'est ce qui va nous arriver je
m'interrogeais
une en charge auguste
ça ne serait pas bien
et puis je ne suis pas tranquille ce
n'est pas le moment je vous assure
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dormir et à manger
[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]
e
à
[Applaudissements]
qui est ce
pour moi
entrée
je voulais vous montrer mon déshabillez
vous savez bien vu
alors bon soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
baba barbara c'est vous l'idée de ce
bruit là vous savez entendu on attrape
et cela êtres monsieur il n'est pas
content parce qu'on sera utile
tape-taupe la fin j'étais dans mon lit
et je pense à vous très fort
je pense à vous très fort
c'est parfait vous me fait bien plaisir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
m
il ya deux pieds dans ma chambre pied de
pieds nus qui dépasse du rideau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
personne ça c'est madame encore un
carreau cassé jaloux disque
n'y allez pas
il faut prévenir monsieur de l'étrange
je m'appelle des seuls
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
c'est le vase de fleurs qui était sur le
coffre dans la médiathèque la porte de
la bibliothèque est fermée
comment ont-ils pu venir jusqu'ici
à
[Musique]
paris
et
[Musique]
or
non n'y allez pas pourquoi ça devient
dangereux pour voir pour moi n'y allez
pas on verra bien
[Applaudissements]
les
[Musique]
c'est une ridicule plaisanterie on se
moque de nous ne comprenez pas
il est pas le y allait pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
barba
charles christ
j'ai très mal j'ai une angoisse cette
souffrance
c'est très grave je peux juste malade
coeur ma chambre sous mon oreiller et en
flac ogg des petites pilules soutenir
avait pu aller chercher mon flacco
pascal astruc mourir comme ça en tout
cas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
notamment la petite bourde que j'ai pu
qu'est ce que c'est que ce gamin
l'autre est deux fois plus grand sa voix
ce n'est pas lui ce n'est pas lui c'est
la voiture tout de même la voiture je
m'en fous de la voiture mais c'est lui
qui joue au casino de la nuit
j'étais pas mamoulian jambes à dire
autre chose tu es minable
[Musique]
ans
barbara
[Musique]
hahahaha
baba
[Musique]
embarras
barbara
[Musique]
raté monsieur il s'est passé cette nuit
dans votre maison d événement grave et
déplorable
vous n'avez rien entendu mon cher
monsieur voilà 50 ans que je suis avec
les fais plus attention
en 1914 à la mobilisation générale
ils sont art il s'est d'ailleurs son
rapport mais j'avais à ce moment là
comme pensionnaire un religieux
d'amérique qui a fait merveille
plus rien calme complet puis ça
recommence et dix ans plus tard vu en
ma première femme elle est engagée une
petite bille 14 ans qui les attirait
pourquoi il y en à comprendre mais
depuis mon second mariage c'est une
sarabande
quand j'ai connu mina c'était une jeune
fille plutôt discrète et réservée en
l'épousant je réveille en elle
bien malgré moi je ne sais quelle force
subtil alors mon cher ami je puis vous
l'avouer j'en ai vu de toutes les
couleurs
la jeune fille qui m'a compagnie a
disparu vous ne me donnez pas la
disparition est un phénomène fréquent
dans cette maison le baron de maulévrier
raconte dans sa chronique une qu'à la
révolution d'une merabet s'accompagner
de 14 de ses filles avaient cherché
refuge dans les caves du château
eh bien on ne les a jamais retrouvé
jamais rien aucune trace qu'est ce que
vous comptez faire rien à faire c'est ce
qu'on appelle la route is il faudra en
prendre son parti
ils sont là et on ne peut rien contre
eux à chacun sa vermine mon attention et
de prévenir la police
la police peut-être j'avoue que je
n'avais pas pensé
ils ont fait un si grand cas des
procédés modernes d'investigation qu'il
est dans les faits très possible tu la
police par yen à deux résultats qui
parlent de police
notre ami vient de me signaler la
disparition de sa jeune temps il est
très en juillet et il se proposait de
l'affairé recherché par la police
ce sont des méthodes les familles
répugne généralement des employés mais
qui dans certains cas sont peut-être
nécessaire elle ne vous avait pas
prévenus de son départ de son départ
vous appelez cela un départ du oui je
les ai aperçus qu'ils franchissaient la
grille quand ce matin très tôt
d'ailleurs sa chambre est vide elle a
emporté sa valise je serai qu'à l'aller
sur ce point la police pourra peut-être
vous renseigner signalé en même temps la
disparition de votre voiture
comment elle est partie avec la voiture
oui ce n'est pas possible il hier soir
elle était en panne il faut croire que
cette demoiselle à des dispositions
particulières pour la mécanique
automobile
mais puisque nous nous expliquons avec
une certaine liberté me semble-t-il
je voudrais vous demander monsieur qui
est cette personne
mina il nous l'a présenté ses cinq ou
six précisément j'aimerais en être sûr
ça n'est pas ma cousine
c'est une amie à vous oui comment
s'appelle-t-elle barbara je préférerais
connaître son nom de famille
elle ne me l'a pas dit
contentons-nous de barbara je trouve
monsieur que vous ne manquez pas d'une
certaine audace sont venus me réclamer
des chambres pour vous et mademoiselle
barbara vous êtes jadot de chez moi
nous étions en panne à la nuit tombée
vous n'étiez pas un messie mais si je
vous assure hier soir ça ne marchait pas
puis vous si vous donné ma parole que
j'accompagnais sept personnes en tout
bien tout honneur
il est vraiment très difficile de vous
croire je suis le second claire de
mettre au couturier notaire à allègre je
connais m au couturier
je dois prendre mes fonctions ce matin
même maître couturier choisit bien mal
son personnel tous orange
et le moine lemoine qui se promènent
sans tête
mina hill a vu le moine c'est rare en
juillet sont des phénomènes paranormaux
monsieur particulier à cette demeure
nous les déplorons mais il n'est pas un
autre pouvoir de les empêcher
[Applaudissements]
je vous remercie madame de votre
hospitalité et je crois tout de même
devoir vous prévenir que je persiste
dans mon intention d'aller me plaindre à
la police
je vous l'avais bien déjà mine à ses
visiteurs devaient nous déranger dans
nos habitudes
je l'avais comme un pressentiment où
allez-vous je serai à l'aigre avant lui
il est peut être encore temps d'éviter
le pire
[Musique]
parfait
à
[Musique]
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]